economía aquí en directo américa me
acompaña en el estudio daniel hablando
con daniela muy buenas noches vamos a
comenzar hablando de un fenómeno
asociado a la inflación pero que muy
pocas veces ocurre y ya está comenzando
a aparecer en varios países de qué se
trata hola santiago muy buenas noches
pues mire con la inflación tan alta en
el mundo ya hay cambios en los hábitos
de consumo por ejemplo en argentina
según el instituto de promoción de la
carne vacuna el consumo anual de carne
cayó el año pasado por primera vez desde
1958 desde que se tienen registros
veamos otros ejemplos de cómo la gente
lo está experimentando en varias
regiones hoy porque lo pagas por ejemplo
mil pesos el tema casi un corte de carne
y el ine ya no sabe si vas a para el
mismo precio o pagas 1200 va subiendo y
la inflación come toda la mercadería eso
con el incremento en el precio de la
comida la gente compra sólo lo necesario
sólo lo básico
de que viene que venía por un kilo del
producto supongamos el aguacate ahora
está llevando de una pieza porque es un
ser básico de la
de la comida mexicana
aguacate con tortilla cualquier relleno
guacamole
todo eso pues ya lo dejas de consumir
mucho porque otros nada más que alcanza
para un aguacate pero el cambio a
santiago no solamente es de los
consumidores la industria también ha
respondido con el fenómeno del que se
hablaba ahora es conocido como en
gameplays jon o reducción que se está
expandiendo por el mundo alejandro reyes
quien es economista jefe del bbva en
colombianos explicó de qué se trata por
el mismo precio estás vendiendo una
calidad inferior del producto que puede
ser vista como base a una calidad
propiamente dicho menor o porque el
volumen del producto el peso del
producto es menor eso es lo que llaman
su inflexión o reducción es que en vez
de ver cambios en precios estamos viendo
cambio en la calidad del producto que se
entrega al final esto es difícil de
medir por parte de las entidades
oficiales dado que la de percibir la
calidad del producto diferencia de la
cal del producto es más difícil que
percibir diferencias en los precios pero
puede ser un fenómeno que afecta
significativamente el bolsillo daniela
muy interesante este fenómeno de los
ejemplos
puntuales que ya se vean en él claro que
ya estén presentes en el día a día por
ejemplo en reino unido en este le redujo
los frascos de café de 100 gramos a 90
gramos el gatorade no sé si ya lo han
notado usted santiago también cambió su
tamaño édgar works que es un defensor
del consumidor en eeuu y ha estado
rastreando este fenómeno durante décadas
y no tiene más ejemplos
este es el papel higiénico en el soft el
viejo tenía 425 hojas en un rollo en mi
sofá y aún se pueden encontrar en
algunas tiendas el nuevo tiene 320 hojas
perdió más de 100 hojas en cada rollo
efe simples porque hay portales aquí por
ejemplo están las toallas de papel es
parte del producto anterior tenía 116
hojas en un rollo el nuevo tiene sólo
110 es agua hunger ends y al respecto
nuestro analista alejandro reyes de bbva
bbva research nos entrega un ejemplo
también de la vida cotidiana en nuestra
región esta vez tenemos el caso de
colombia y tienes un producto que te
cuesta 100 pesos el siguiente nivel de
cambio sería que costará 150 pesos esos
50 binacionales quizás es mucho
incremento para el valor de ese producto
y cuando la unidad de cambio es tan
acotado tan pequeña el producto pues
tiene un valor pequeño pues tiende a ser
más fácil reducir la calidad del
producto antes que mover
el producto el mejor ejemplo para esto
es el pan en muchas oportunidades han
visto ustedes que el pan tiene un peso
peso fijo y un precio fijo pero lo van a
chi cando a medida que pasa el tiempo
hasta que pueden hacer un ajuste de
precio y lo suficientemente
significativo y ahí y vuelven a ver un
cambio en la calidad bueno pagamos lo
mismo o un poco más por menos de qué
depende entonces daniela que en una
economía haya o no reeducación bueno es
un fenómeno primero hay que decir lo que
no es nuevo pero que es más evidente
cuando hay altísimos niveles de
inflación como los de ahora eeuu acaba
de informar por ejemplo que los precios
de su canasta familiar subieron 8,6 por
ciento hasta mayo el mayor aumento en 40
años veamos que dicen los expertos bueno
exponente m cuando he hablado con los
fabricantes me dicen que están
experimentando costos de mano de obra
más altos cuesta más llevar los
productos a la tienda sus costos de
materia prima están aumentando entonces
se enfrentan a un problema que hacemos
subimos el precio directamente pero
saben que los consumidores se darán
cuenta de eso y no estarán contentos y
tal vez cambien de marca y si le
quitarán un poco al producto de esa
manera están disfrazando un aumento de
precio que saben que muchos consumidores
no van a captar muchas gracias daniela
es todo por el momento en este primer
bloque informativo a continuación kobe
19 la semana en américa siga con
nosotros